welcome everyone to my talk do you
follow what I'm explaining a
practitioner's guide to opening the AI
black box for humans
um as mentioned I'm kylian I'm speaking
to you from beautiful Hamburg Germany up
in the north of Germany and while I'm
trained as a physicist I do have a PhD
on the design of human AI interactions
with explainable AI and I currently work
as the co-founder of an early stage
startup called indignity where we use
explainable AI to build tools to enable
human agency in an AI driven world
everything I'm going to talk about and a
lot of further information on background
material and also these slides you will
be able to find on GitHub I'm at ionic
Solutions there the slides are not yet
uploaded but I will upload them after
the talk and I will also show the link
before we conclude in case you didn't
have time to jot it down just yet
um in this talk uh what I want to speak
about is to um is explaining
um AI systems to lay users or to users
that are not data scientists or ml
engineers and very briefly um what this
looks like is that we do have some what
I would like to call an AI system which
has an input then there's some sort of
model might be a machine learning model
could also be a different algorithm and
then we have a system output and now you
have some sort of an audience maybe
users of an app that you're building or
of an internal tool you're developing
that are wondering and asking you lots
of questions so why did this mysterious
system map a certain input to a certain
output this is what this talk is about
I've structured it into four parts and
one example at the end where we will
look at a practical example of how you
could actually implement this in
practice
um and um yeah because we only have 30
minutes today let's Jump Right In
in the first part I would like to talk
about three truths about AI that I think
are very important to keep in mind when
explaining
um yeah AI systems uh to others
and uh the first truth is
that there are no true black boxes in Ai
and I know that this might sound a bit
controversial and if you're consuming a
lot of media or participate in the
occasional LinkedIn discussion on that
topic uh you might be led to believe
that there's something very mysterious
in transparent about how especially uh
large deep Learning Systems uh behave or
are built up and I would argue that
actually we do not at least not in that
sense have a transparency issue in AI
but at the end of the day in my mind
it's all maths and bit flipping right so
it's human-made structures and for
example compared to trying to understand
the human brain where it's really
difficult to measure something
and we don't know a lot about the
details right and we certainly do not
have the full picture if we're running
machine Learning Systems even like huge
Transformer models in principle we can
have a look at all these CPU GPU
instructions that I calculated we can
look at the memory at every point in
time that we want to and this is a huge
advantage sets also when we're trying to
explain uh what's going on there
on the other hand though almost
everything that you have ever created in
terms of software doesn't even need to
be AI will be a black box to your users
that's the second truth which also makes
it challenging because even if you have
a very simple algorithm a very simple
model you might just be adding a couple
of numbers
from your user's point of view even the
most simple of models will be um very
opaque when viewed from the outside
um
uh so and you you will probably all know
this you're interacting with some piece
of software
um you're typing something in and you
get a certain response and you wonder
why that actually occurred
and so if we're talking about black
boxes or Black Box AI systems for the
sake of this talk also if you think
about the title of this talk I'm talking
about this kind of system so there's
nothing inherently black box but it's
something which seems to be a black box
uh to your users
and finally the third truth in the first
part is that your users don't really
care about your model and I think this
is one of the first things that many
data scientists when they start to try
to explain and generate explanations for
the AI systems for some other groups of
stakeholders where they are misled is
that they of course do care about your
model if you're a data scientist and
you're training your
um your machine learning image
classifier for example and it's
consistently getting certain samples
wrong you might um go and use an
explainable AI or interpretable machine
learning method to really dig into the
details if you're a researcher you might
try to use these methods to figure out
whether there's a tweak you can do to
your algorithmic structure of your
models to make it even better or to
understand why certain patterns do work
and certain patterns do not but your
users don't care
um they don't want to know what the
algorithmic structure is they don't care
about all the fancy calculations that
you do what they care about is the
decision or the recommendation or the
prediction that your model effects and
so when you're asking for explanations
um this is the level
um which you need to explain on and
we'll return to this um in one of the
later parts
um with that said uh with these three
truths under our belt
um I would like to give you the first
definition
um or it's more like a working
um on the kind of subfield of
explainable AI I'll be speaking about
today which I like to call user-centric
explainable AI and that's the field of
research and practice if you will that
aims to enable humans to manage the
complexity of AI systems by generating
explanations for their outputs or their
internal workings
and naturally this already leads us into
part two
um which leads us to the question what
actually is an explanation what are we
talking about when we say that we are
explaining something to someone and the
first thing to realize here is that
explaining is inherently a social
activity and you can see this with a
little experiment that I would like to
conduct with you right now unfortunately
we cannot talk to each other but you can
just
um imagine in your mind what you would
say to me when I ask you why are you
here
why are you sitting in front of your
computer somewhere on this planet uh
listening to me talk about explainable
AI
and um if you've done this the chances
are really high that you've come up with
a sentence like oh I skipped the program
this morning this sounded really
interesting or I actually do have a
project at work or at school where I'm
looking into explainability so I wanted
to learn more right and so you picked um
uh you you were very quick to come up
with an explanation of why you were here
that you could potentially say to me but
on the other hand probably no one of you
in the audience thought or said
something like well I woke up this
morning or a couple of decades ago I was
born or something like this which is
also a very important part uh why you
actually ended up here in this session
or why you might be watching this later
on YouTube or something but you wouldn't
say this as an explanation and even
though we are from very different
cultural backgrounds presumably and we
don't really know each other you were
able to come up with an explanation that
I would find
um very satisfying that I would accept
as an explanation and as you can so you
can see that it's like really an
interaction between two people and
context matters a whole lot
um
also what's important to keep in mind
and that's also a trap that you can fall
into as a data scientist and that I fell
into myself at one point as well as um
that you try to
um explain the entire causality chain or
when explaining AI systems but when you
think about
um how you explain from Human to human
you never start at I don't know the big
bang and then at some point metaformed
and then the solar system formed and
then planet Earth appeared and then life
appeared and at some point you were born
right that's all part um of um most
things that you do in life somehow
really big relate back to something like
the big bang but you would never put
this in an explanation
um and so and that's also true when
explaining AI systems people do not want
to know everything but what they're
looking for um is an explanation and an
explanation when viewed from that angle
um is essentially is a skill it's an art
maybe of selecting the proper kind of
causes from this almost infinite
causality chain and from all these
little steps and calculations that maybe
your AI system is doing to select the
ones that comprise what the human would
accept as an explanation
and to make this a little bit less meta
and more practical
um let's look at another definition and
this is something which I took from the
four principles of explainable
artificial intelligence it's a paper by
nist the National Institute of Standards
and Technology was published uh about I
think 14 months ago and they um it's a
very practical framework for thinking
about these kind of things and they say
that an explanation is something which
delivers or contains evidence or reasons
for outputs and or processes
um and that's still quite vague but it's
very practical because we're no longer
talking about um explaining like giving
a full list of causes
um or being able to to deterministically
uh describe something
um in its full complexity but we're
looking for for providing evidence for
providing reasons but it doesn't need to
be exhaustive
and so moving on into part three we've
discovered uh that we kind of have an
understanding of what an explanation is
what explaining is about and let's look
at um what's actually a good explanation
right so we want to produce something
which works as an explanation which
people will accept
and
again there's it's always a bit of a
disappointment on the first slide of
these parts
um in quite a daunting task because the
quality and usefulness of explanations
are to very highly subjective qualities
or properties of explanations
and um you can you can see this or you
you will have experienced this
throughout your life you come up with a
good explanation for something
um or you tell tell a certain story a
certain way to a number of people and it
works quite well and then you tell it to
your grandparents or you tell it to a
toddler or you're in a different
situation in a different context and it
no longer works and some people
um even though 90 of people will agree
that something is a good explanation you
will always find that one person that
doesn't agree that it is a good
explanation and that's fine it actually
also makes explaining things a bit
easier because the bar is not as high
whereas in machine learning you might be
used to these 90 plus percent accuracy
numbers in a lot of tasks or even 99
accuracy numbers and a lot of tasks
um that's really not the case in
explainability uh so if you can produce
something which the majority of your
audience finds um useful finds to be of
high quality and likes that's usually a
very good result already
and the second consequence of that fact
is that you cannot capture these
concepts with simple metrics a lot of
people try to come up with metrics for
the explainability or to measure how
comprehensive an explanation is how
realistic it is how good it is and I
would argue that all of these attempts
are bound to fail because there's so
much complexity going on so much
additional context information that goes
into crafting a good explanation that
just by coming up with a number of
equations a number of measures or
metrics to to then Benchmark
explanations with that's probably not
going to work and that's very similar
actually to what we see a lot in natural
language processing for example in in
text summarization or in question
answering or in text generation it's
really really difficult to come up even
with um yeah what I would like to call
proxy measures or something which
approximates the quality of the text as
it is perceived by humans and also there
we run into this issue um all the time
and to give you uh as some insight into
what a lot of people think are qualities
of good explanations and why it's not so
easy consider the statement which you
can find a lot especially in the
academic literature on explainability
where there's the sentiment that short
explanations are better and they're
always better and you should try to be
as concise as possible and not create
too lengthy um explanations and at first
sight seems to make a lot of sense right
it's quite obvious nobody wants to read
really long answers or explanations but
on the other hand if you've ever tried
to put a very short explanations in
front of humans you might have noticed
that um it's not that simple it doesn't
seem to be the case at least not always
and so we don't really know whether
that's true or not but I would argue
that it's like that it's definitely not
always true
um
and to give you a little bit of insight
into one study that I ran during my my
PhD I promised these are the only two uh
plots with data in here
um what we did essentially is to give
people two explanations for the very
same outcome that an AI system produced
and then asked them to pick
um pick one of them uh the one they
preferred in that situation uh that's a
standard experiment setup in explainable
Ai and we also had some way to measure
the length so we we used essentially the
number of features of input features
that um uh an explanation invoked in
order to explain the outcome and then we
um we asked them to pick one of the two
and we also asked them um whether the
explanation is longer or shorter and you
can see that this measure that we came
up with correlates quite well with
perception
um of course it's much easier with
length than for example with something
like realism it's almost impossible to
come up with a measure for realism but
you can see that this kind of um kind of
works so if it's really longer then
people also perceive it as longer and if
it's shorter then people also perceive
it as shorter so that's fine that's very
consistent and then if you look at the
data you see that in sixty percent of
cases users preferred explanations
um and not just explanations that were
longer but actually they prefer them
because they were longer so they
explicitly said I like this explanation
more because it's longer
um
of course there's a lot more details uh
to this than than you can see on this
slide but at the end of the day the
conclusion should be that uh Beware of
simple metrics and we we have statements
um like um shorter explanations are
better uh you really need to figure this
out
um in the situation that you're working
in
um but um again we'll return to to the
paper by this the four principles of
explainable AI uh to again get some more
practical
um things to work with and something
which is maybe better than saying
something is useful or high quality the
first one uh the first property of
explanations that they um carved out as
the the explanations accuracy which
means that the explanation correctly
reflects the reasons for generating the
AI systems output and or accurately
reflects its internal processes and
that's something which is very technical
um so that's this is something which you
can um for most explanations and
explanation Methods at least that you
can assess without even ever asking a
human
um because you can check whether what
what your explain explainability
algorithm output matches uh what the
model is doing on a more technical level
and so we'll not go into more detail on
this here
um but the second property is what we
continue to uh to work with is the
meaningfulness which means that the
provided explanations are understandable
to the intended consumers and this is
something which is very important and is
quite often overlooked especially when
you come from this technical accuracy
perspective and then all of a sudden you
start to show your explanations to some
others
um because it's also very easy to not
only have something which is meaningless
but it's also very easy to generate
explanations that are misleading and
there are some nice studies which I um
linked on the guitar page that
accompanies this talk where you can see
that even data science Prof
professionals if you for example show
them bar chart or bar charts or feature
importance
analyzes or something that they can be
very easily misled accidentally but also
intentionally
and moving on into part four I think we
all agree that we want to generate
explanations that are meaningful but how
do we do this
and the most important part at least
from my point of view to consider here
is that from the user's point of view
there's not just one stage of pre and
post processing that you're used to as a
data scientist but there are actually
two stages of pre-imposed processing uh
and let me explain this
um so what you um are usually looking at
as a data scientist is the AI system
that we also saw in the beginning so you
have your input you do some
pre-processing
um and then um you um take whatever the
model outputs and um yeah and then you
do some post-processing and convert it
into something which is then sent to
your Downstream consumers
um we can take the example of an image
classifier so you have this image of a
cat
which is fed into the system then the
pre-processing usually looks like
something that's depicted here so you
will resize the image uh you will make
it maybe make it Square you will have to
um change something about the color
channels um perhaps and then you have an
image classification model in this case
and what this outputs is a vector of the
different class likelihoods and then in
post-processing you determine which is
the most likely class and also what um
what what the label for that class is
and then you look up that label and then
you output a string and this is the
level on which you can assess for
example the technical accuracy of an
explanation and which you you are used
to evaluating models on but actually uh
from your users perspective already an
image of a cat is something which is
highly pre-processed because no one
nobody no human at least that I know
conceives the world in three or four
dimensional tensors uh with lots of um
individual pixel values in them but we
see an object we see an animal and also
if I read the word a cat it's much more
than just a string it's much more than a
number of utf-8 characters
um in some byte encoding but it's
actually something which invokes some
sort of emotion
um and maybe with a cat it's quite
Universal what people perceive but if
you think about a more complex setting
then it's not too difficult to imagine
that people might be very easily misled
also just simply by the statements or
the visualizations that your
explainability system then outputs and
so if you want to evaluate
meaningfulness you always need to do
this in your user's world and it's very
important to understand the context that
they're working in
yeah finally and I think that's kind of
follows from that is that only the users
know what's meaningful and the emphasis
should be on the only there's no way to
uh to have a shortcut here there's no
way to engineer your way around this
there's no way to guess what your users
will think is Meaningful but the only
way to figure this out is to to ask them
you can do this directly or you can do
this indirectly by observing their
behavior but if you don't do this
there's no way of knowing this
yeah so um also with regards to time
let's move into an example um and we
will try in the last five or six minutes
to generate meaningful explanations for
Real Estate price predictions
so the scenario is as follows imagine
you're on a real estate website and um
there's there you have the opportunity
to enter data about a house might be
your house that you're trying to sell
might be a house that you're looking to
buy and in any case this data is fed
into an AI system some pre-processing
going on as we've just seen and then
there's a pricing model
that estimates what um what the price
for this house um could be
um and what this um what the system
believes uh that you could um get for if
you put it for sale and um now you have
users that are wondering why a certain
price estimate was given so why is my
house worth X
and if we now start to understand what
the users are actually asking so that do
they want to see the pricing model I
mean presumably you don't want to give
the pricing model to them but also you
will know if you've ever worked in price
estimation especially in real estate
um that this is very very complex there
are so many factors like for example the
reputation of a neighborhood very
difficult to put into numbers this is
why machine learning is so great because
you can just learn this from historical
data
um but if you then dig a bit deeper or
You observe how for example user people
talk to their real estate agents or talk
to each other about house prices uh what
they're really asking is why is my house
worth X instead of being worth a
different amount so why is my house more
expensive than my neighbor's house
um why was it uh why was my friend able
to buy a house much cheaper uh than um
what is than the price that is offered
to me now
um so um and even if they don't
explicitly ask the second part of the
question that's what they usually do
when they ask why is something worth X
and that's uh something we can answer as
data scientists right so we just need to
find a data point for which the pricing
model that we use predicts a higher
price let's say we're going for the for
this direction
um
and then you will figure out that there
are indeed algorithms which can do this
um which are called counter factual
explanations and the ideas that we have
this one data point which is marked as X
for which the model predicts a certain
price
um and then in order to to obtain a
different price why we just need to move
that data point to a different part of
the input space and slowly optimize our
way towards their where the model
outputs a different price y
uh you can already tell um they are
essentially infinitely many uh possible
locations we could move this point to
and most of them will not make up a good
explanation
um because
um your model doesn't knows how to break
prices and for example one way to
increase the price of a house is to just
have more rooms to it for example and
then um you will just add more rooms you
will get a higher price but that's
really not a feasible house it's not
meaningful it's completely unsuitable or
you could just add more stories or
something like this or move it uh to to
the suburb of a
of a big city
um that might be feasible in some in
some sense and people might like that
but usually it's very confusing you
would much rather have a house which
could actually sit in the same location
um and um maybe has like an upgraded
heating system
and so what we need to do is we need to
find a data point for which the pricing
model predicts a higher price
that is also perceived as realistic and
typical and that's something we can do
I'm not going to go into detail here we
just add a number more terms and
boundary conditions to our
counterfactual explanation algorithm and
then the question is how do we know
whether users actually think that
they're realistic and typical and if
you've uh not fallen asleep throughout
this talk you will know that we need to
go ask them and we can actually do this
directly and one trick I can recommend
here or one suggestion I want to make is
to not reinvent the wheel but to
actually use something which are
established constructs and in the
example I've given here we went to
Communications and media research and
constructs are essentially sets of
questions that you can ask to assess
whether a certain property is true about
something and so we just uh yeah took
some ideas from different research
papers there use these constructs and
were able to determine what we needed to
do in order so that people actually
thought something was a realistic and
typical house and then you arrive at
something which looks like this
which are you can of course display this
in very different forms but as a
sentence you arrive at something like
okay everything else being equal about
your house the house would be worth 600k
instead of 350 it was built in 2005
instead of 1999 at a living space of 233
square meters instead of 190 and a lot
size of 714 instead of 490 and I think
this all makes sense that's a house
you've probably seen in your life it's
conceivable that this would um yeah um
yeah that such a house would exist and
the real estate agent would point to
such a house in order to explain to you
uh the price estimate
um
yeah
from the audience
yes let me quickly um conclude with the
summary and then happy to take one or
two questions thank you
um yeah so you can see my summary slide
here um we've talked about explanations
we talked about meaningfulness we talked
about accuracy and in the last a couple
of minutes I walked you through an
example of how to actually do this in
practice which starts with understanding
the context and the audience then the
selection of an algorithm
um that can provide the desires answers
and then to evaluate everything for
accuracy and meaningfulness
um yeah and now I'm happy to take a
couple of questions just want to again
point you to my GitHub repository as
well and give a quick shout out to the
explainable Isla Community you can find
all the information how to join on
Twitter and also um at the GitHub
repository thank you and now looking
forward to your questions
foreign
okay so the question is what kind of
explanations were given in this short
long comparison could you add a couple
of examples to your git
um yes I can do that um I have already
linked the research papers about that
um so essentially these were
explanations uh textual explanations
very similar to the example which we've
just seen But for um for like a plant
species app so you have a smartphone app
and you take a photograph of a leaf for
example or some plant and then the AI
system explains to you what kind of tree
um this Leaf belongs to and this was
kind of the the setting that we use in
order to assess different properties and
qualities of explanations and everything
all the details are in the git yeah are
there requirements for actionable
explanations yes that's a really really
good point
um
um I haven't didn't have the time to go
into detail yeah so if you want
something to be actionable then it's not
only sufficient that the counter example
is realistic but you also need to make
sure that you can actually go there um I
think one easy example to understand is
that if you're applying for a job and
they tell you that you should um that
you or you're applying for a loan for
example and they'll tell you that you
need to be 20 years older that doesn't
really help you but if they tell you
that you need to accept a higher
interest rate maybe or a higher security
deposit that's something which you could
conceivably do or to lower your spending
yeah and so you always need to
understand the context of your users
sometimes they are looking for something
that they can change and act upon but
sometimes it also doesn't matter again
it depends on the situation